[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHALINI GOVIL-PAI:
So I'm Shalini.
I head up Android TV.
Thank you very much for
joining us in this session
around developing
for Android TV.
So as Rick alluded to in
the keynote this morning,
the home is really undergoing
some major disruptions,
starting with broadband getting
better to the homes leading
to more connected devices.
OTT services really becoming
mainstream in the home.
And voice technologies
creating very simple
interfaces with which to
connect to different devices
within your home.
Having said that, we still find
that people's favorite place
to come home to is still the TV.
People are watching TV
more than they have ever
done before, more than
phones, more than tablets.
It is TVs that people
come back home to,
and more and more these
TVs are your gateway
into the connected home.
In addition, as I
mentioned, OTT services
are one of the ways people are
watching content on their TVs.
And in fact, this
data is US data
but this is actually true
worldwide, 64% of users
have at least one
subscription that they
are consuming on their TVs.
And I would say
probably in this room,
you have at least more than two.
And like I said, this
is a global phenomenon.
That is really the
beauty of Android TV.
It provides one place for
users to watch content,
whether it's coming
from their live TV,
or whether it's coming
from an OTT app,
And one place to play their
favorite games powered
by the Play Store.
And that is really the momentum
that Android TV is creating.
Many of you may
know-- or may not--
that we have two tiers that
we offer to our partners.
The retail tier is what
we offer to our OEMs,
including Sony TV and
streaming devices.
And this is powered by a Android
Forward user experience that
showcases Assistant, Cast,
and the Play Store, as well
as YouTube.
The second tier is what we
offer to our operators, which
in addition to the
beauty of what we provide
on the retail tier, also offers
them an experience that they
can provide to their subscribers
in what we call the operator
mode.
Because of this phenomenal
flexibility and, of course,
the power of Android--
which is what Android
TV resides on--
we are seeing phenomenal
success in the market.
And I'm really happy to announce
six of the top 10 smart TV OEMs
have signed up with Android TV.
And worldwide we have signed
up 140 plus operator partners.
[APPLAUSE]
Because of this momentum--
and thanks to you and
all of your support--
we are also happy to announce
1,000 plus streaming content
providers, including
Amazon Prime, which
is now available broadly on
all Android TV platforms--
So we have really leaned
in to our app developers--
and 5,000 plus Android
TV apps that are
prevalent in the TV app store.
And so with that success, I'm
going to hand it over to Anwar,
who's going to talk
a little bit more
about all the exciting things
that are coming in Android TV
and how you can use them
for your own success.
[APPLAUSE]
ANWAR HANEEF:
Thank you, Shalini.
Hi, my name is Anwar Haneef.
I lead product for Android TV
ecosystem and integrations.
I want to share a memorable
personal, professional, moment
that I had a couple
of months ago.
I had my 70-year-old
father visit,
and I explained to him how
he could control his Android
TV using his voice using
a Google Home device.
For the first time in his life--
I won't ever forget
the expression
that he had-- for the
first time in his life
he felt like technology
understood him as opposed
to the other way around.
Without the need for
a remote control,
he could control his TV, he
could control his lights,
all with the simplicity
of his voice.
Now on the other hand, for my
adorable but mildly annoying
seven-year-old daughter,
voice control TV and lights
creates a whole different story.
That's a story for another time.
At Google, whether you're 70
or seven-year-old or somewhere
in between, at Google,
we're committed
to making the lives of our
users better with technology.
One way we're doing this is
by using the Google Assistant
to become a helpful
backdrop to your lives,
helping connect you with the
other technology in your lives.
And in this new world
of connected devices
and technology at
home, Android TV
is the platform that
Google is developing
for the biggest and most
important screen at home.
Ever since TV was invented, it
served one key purpose, which
is helping us watch media.
With the Google Assistant,
we have the opportunity
to change and evolve the
role of TV in our lives,
to make it more
helpful and help us
become a conduit to accessing
other technologies at home.
This is the direction that
we want to take Android TV.
And this vision can
only become successful
if it's shared by our
partners in our ecosystem.
Only with your help can
we make this reality true.
We heard your feedback.
We've spoken to several of you.
And we started to
act on that feedback.
Number one, we
heard that you want
us to help make it easier
for you to develop apps
on Android TV.
At the same time, you
wanted to make it easier
for you to participate in the
Google Assistant ecosystem.
You want to make opportunity--
you want us to help you
with opportunities to make your
content shine in our platform.
And you want us to help
you fuel your innovation
by helping you commercialize
and make commerce
easier on Android TV.
I'm excited to share with
you a couple of examples
of the things that we've
done in the past year,
as well as new initiatives
and new features
that we're launching
coming soon.
Android TV's strength is
in the range and breadth
of devices, and form factors,
and devices at different price
points that's available today.
But we've also heard
that, as a developer,
the variability in devices
can make it a little bit more
challenging in terms of being
able to address these devices.
Earlier this year, we
launched Reference +.
This is a program by which
we simplify and reduce
the variability in hardware
so that, as a developer,
you can more easily address
the target devices that you're
addressing on Android TV.
Reference + devices are
also Google Assistant ready.
This ensures a consistent
performance and behavior
across devices from
multiple manufacturers.
Today, we're working
with 10 TV manufacturers,
and we'll be working
with more over time.
With the proliferation
of streaming content,
creating a great media
discovery experience
is something that we found
to be extremely critical
for our users as well
as for our developers.
Earlier, Android TV
launched a user experience
which gave users multiple
options by which they
can access their content,
including the ability
to jump in right into their
favorite content from the home
screen.
Many partners have embraced the
channels and have built their--
and are starting to see
great engagement and response
and impact because of
embracing channels.
Some of our partners
are seeing up to 70%
increase in watch
time and up to 78%
increase in views by
embracing channels.
Users are staying more engaged
and create more opportunities
for our media
partners to monetize
through this engagement.
But we're not stopping there.
What I'd like to talk about
next is some of the new features
that we're introducing
in the coming year.
The Google Assistant is
built into Android TV.
And we've enabled users to
control their on-demand content
using voice.
Today, we're lending our voice
to more of our media partners.
Coming soon, Assistant
knows what's on live TV
and will allow you to use your
voice to instantly switch over
to live content that you
have playing on your TV.
Philo is one of
the first partners
that are working with us.
And I would invite you to
stop over at our Sandbox
to see a live demo.
As the media and app ecosystem
for Android TV grows,
we know it's important for
us to create opportunities
for you, our ecosystem partners,
to drive discovery of the app
and content that
you're developing.
To help with that, we're
developing new ways
by which we can curate and
highlight high-quality content
on the home screen.
And this is supported by our
editorial team at Google Play.
Expect to see more coming
out soon in this space.
Our user insights indicate that
users are a lot more engaged
in the app search, discovery,
and browsing process
when they really understand
the content experience
and media within the apps
that are available on the Play
Store.
That's why, today, I'm
excited to announce
that we're launching a complete
refresh of the Play Store
on Android TV.
[APPLAUSE]
Coming later this year,
the new Play Store
offers a much more immersive
discovery experience,
where the media and content
experiences are highlighted
more prominently and creates
a much more engaged discovery
experience for our users.
Lastly, we heard from you.
You're driving innovation and
your investing in content.
And sustaining that innovation
and investment requires fuel.
This is one of the
most popular requests
that we received
from our ecosystem.
We need to make it easier for
users to buy and subscribe
on Android TV.
Later this year, we'll be
rolling out an updated user
experience that brings the
best of Google Play billing
onto Android TV.
This includes a
simplified user experience
that simplifies commerce on
TV, including functionality
such as subscribe and install.
This will allow your users
to not only install an app,
but also subscribe to your
service or from the Play Store.
Secondly, we're introducing
PIN functionality.
This will further streamline the
purchasing process on Android
TV and make it much more
easier without the need
for a password.
Purchases on Android TV will
now be smoother, faster,
and more seamless.
So what I spoke about today--
I spoke about a couple
of different things.
One, we're tying in and leaning
into the Google Assistant
ecosystem.
Number two, we're
highlighting and creating
opportunities to highlight the
content that you're creating
within from our ecosystem.
And lastly, we're simplifying
commerce on Android TV.
These are just a few of
the ways by which we're
bringing the best of
Google onto Android TV.
As we move towards richer
Google Assistant experiences
in the home, Android TV as
the largest screen at home
is a critical pillar of Google's
strategy in the living room.
Getting here has been
an incredible effort.
And I thank you for all that
effort and all the commitment
that you've had to
help us getting here.
I'm really excited about what we
are introducing today, and all
of the innovations that we
have baking in the labs.
I really look forward
to working with you
and look forward
to seeing what we
can innovate with you together.
With that, I'll
hand it over to Ben,
who will help us walk through
how some of these innovations
can be used in your apps.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BENJAMIN BAXTER: Thanks, Anwar.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Benjamin Baxter.
I was on developer
relations as a developer
advocate for Android TV.
I recently joined as an
engineer on the Android TV team.
I want to talk about all
the things Anwar just said,
but how you can do
them in your app today.
But first, I'm really pleased to
announce some adoption numbers
for Android OS.
We now have over 80%
of Android TV devices
running Nougat and above.
By the end of the year, we
should see 60% running Oreo.
This is amazing.
With Oreo, we decoupled
the launcher from the OS.
This enables us to update
faster and give users
better experiences much easier.
You don't have to wait for the
next Android operating system
just to get the newest features.
Let's dive into these features.
The three things
Anwar talked about
were the Assistant, how to
bring your content forward
on the home screen, and
how to make your app easier
for commerce.
Let's start with the Assistant.
I'm really proud to
announce three main things.
One, watch actions, live
TV, and playback controls.
Watch actions are a way
for you to say, "Hey,
Google I want to watch 'Avengers
Infinity War.'" Across all
of our surfaces-- web,
mobile, and especially TV--
we're able to showcase
your app as a platform
to watch that content.
All you have to do as an
app developer is supply
your content to
Google, and we can say,
hey, this app has your content.
We've updated that
to support live TV.
So now if you have a complex
electronic programming
guide and EPG, you
can submit that
as part of your
Content Catalog, and we
can surface this live TV content
across all of our surfaces.
In addition, we've updated
all of our documentation
about these watch actions.
Next, with search, we've also
added operator integrations.
So if you're a TV
operator, you can
have custom actions presented
to the user, such as DVR
and record now.
As a user, they can
still select more options
and see your app that has
that content in search.
Lastly, I want to talk
about playback controls.
We've made them even
easier with ExoPlayer.
For playback controls, you
need to have a media session.
What you're able to do now
is listen for callbacks
from the user, such
as when they say,
"Hey, Google, skip
forward five minutes."
You end up getting these
callbacks through a media
session callback.
With ExoPlayer, we made
this easier by connecting
those two together.
Let's dive further.
Here, we're making a
media session, which just
takes in a context in a tag.
And then we set it to active.
And if you have other things
you need to set, like the media
session state or what
your player is doing,
set that at this time as well.
Once you have an instance
to your media session,
go ahead and find your
ExoPlayer instance.
With those two, you can create
a MediaSession connector.
This is a new
classroom and extension
library from ExoPlayer.
Here we create a media
MediaSession connector,
and we pass in that
media session instance.
Later, we just call set
player, and we give it
the ExoPlayer instance.
The MediaSession
connector handles
all of those playback controls
and all the callbacks for you.
If you do need to customize
it, it's super simple.
You can add in all the extra
customization you need.
Say you have a music
playlist, and you
want to customize
the queuing system,
you can do that super
simple with this.
So to wrap that up, we've
implemented new live TV
integrations.
We've updated our documentation
and watch actions.
And we made playback controls
even easier with ExoPlayer.
Let's talk about
the home screen.
This is where your
content can really shine.
The first thing you notice
as a user is the app.
The app shows up and represents
your branding and your content
with a banner.
We've discovered
some best practices,
and we just want to
go over them quickly.
Here we have this
beautiful app Banner Best
Practice, my new favorite app.
However, the banner matters.
In this case, we're
reusing the mobile icon,
and we notice that
the app icon becomes
very scrunched and hard to see.
This could lead to a
bad user experience
and not represent
your branding well.
On the opposite side
of the spectrum,
here we have an image
that's too large,
and gets scaled,
and might be blurry.
You really want to have a
banner that's 320 by 180.
You also want to put that
banner in the XHDPI folder.
If you put it in
just drawable, it's
going to be recognized
as an MDPI folder,
and this could lead to scaling
and blurriness with your image.
Also note, we do reuse your
banner in certain contexts.
Depending where
the user is and we
need to represent
your branding, we
reuse that banner
across the home screen.
So the home screen-- real fast
time to tie in to what Anwar
talked about earlier--
really comprises
of three things.
Channels-- these are
rows that you can
surface content to the user.
In addition, there's also a play
next row that's system managed,
and you can add content
there for the users
to quickly hop back in.
Finally, you can
have video previews.
For example, here we
have an immersive preview
from Red Bull.
And we've seen increased
engagement from apps
that support video previews.
How does this work
under the covers?
Your app is going to
talk to the launcher
through a content provider.
You can send over any
data, games, music, video
that your app has,
and the launcher
is going to store that in
the TV provider database.
Since we're using
the content provider,
we're able to do some
optimizations that
are pretty cool.
If you used the content
provider before,
you may be use to content
provider operations.
We can optimize all
of these operations
when we go to update the
home screen by doing this
all in bulk.
So for example, we make
a call to our back end,
and we get a list
of content that we
need to add to the home screen.
We can look through that
content and look through what's
in our channel and say, hey,
here's a bunch of new content
that we need to add and
create a new operation to add
that content.
This creates an
operation that we can
add to our list of operations.
Or vice versa, we can also say
these pieces of content need
to be removed and create
delete operations.
Finally, whatever is left, we
should just update and make
a bunch of update operations.
When we're done, we can
apply all of these in batch.
This allows us to
have one transaction
and optimize the performance
with the home screen.
I'm also happy to announce
that with AndroidX, we
made this easier for you.
You don't have to worry
about content providers
when using AndroidX.
Let's take a look.
Here we have a preview
channel helper.
And in this helper, you can
add all the metadata you need.
And lastly, you
can add the logo.
The logo should be
an 80 by 80 picture.
And as the system, we're
going to apply a mask
and show a final image that
might be different then what
you supplied.
Think of it like adaptive
icons for a mobile,
but not quite the same.
What matters most is that you
supply an 80 by 80 image for us
to use.
Once you have your channel,
you just add publish channel,
and this does everything as
one transaction for you--
no more content provider.
Once you get the channel
ID, you should store this
for synchronizing
later where you
might want to use those batch
operations from a content
provider.
Next, I want to talk
about the play next row.
Over the past couple of years,
I've worked with a lot of apps,
and TV shows really shine
on the play next row.
This is an example
from the DC universe
app, where they have
strong indications
to watch "Young Justice."
As a user, you could be
halfway through a show.
Here we're 10 minutes
into a 21-minute episode,
and then you leave.
And when you leave,
as an app, you
can add strong notes
and UI indicators, "Hey,
you're halfway through."
In addition, you can add this
content to the play next row.
One thing we noticed
is that there's
a piece of metadata called
last engagement time.
This sounds pretty trivial.
It represents the last
timestamp a user or an app
has interacted with
that piece of content.
Here for example, when
the user pauses the show,
that should be the timestamp
for last engagement time.
When the user goes back in and
they finish watching the show
and they see the credits,
this is a great time
to add a next episode
to the play next row.
Here DC adds the next episode.
We're able to give strong
visual indicators to the user,
"This' is the next episode.
Here's where you left off."
But the timestamp for last
engagement time should change.
This should be the time
the credits came up.
This is technically
the last time
the user has interacted
with that season.
If you think of
that as a season,
last engagement time
makes more sense
since they haven't interacted
with the next episode.
The last part of the lifecycle
of a TV show is new episode.
So a new piece of content
for "Young Justice"
hasn't come out yet.
It'll be aired at a later date.
So user has not
interacted with that yet.
You can still add that
to the home screen
and set the last
engagement time to the time
when the episode is aired.
The launcher sees that
that time is in the future
and will handle the
content accordingly.
There's a bunch of pros and
cons and dos and don'ts.
The key rule of
thumb is if a user
interacts with a piece
of content, that's
fair game for the home screen.
Lastly, I want to talk about how
to make your app more friendly
and be prepared for
when these changes come
for commerce later, such
as Anwar talked about.
Mainly, it comes down
to distributing your app
in the Play Store.
You need to do a few things.
One, in your manifest
file, declare that you
use the lean back feature.
Two, make sure you have
the lean back intent
to filter for your
main activity.
The last thing you need to do is
when you're in your Play Store
listing, go to pricing
and distribution
and select this check box.
What this does is this enables
a process that sends your app
to the Play Store review team.
They're going to review
your app for simple things,
like D-pad support, app
crashes, and gives you a report
if it doesn't support this.
This helps ensure that we
have a basic bar of quality
for the Android TV apps.
We have documented
what those checks
are on developer.Android.com.
By having your app on
the Play Store, when
we support features
like subscriber
install later this year, you're
already ahead of the game
and can start
making money faster.
So in conclusion then, the three
things we've been focusing on
are making your app
easier to integrate
with the Assistant, such as
with live TV and watch actions.
Having your content really shine
on the home screen requires
a little effort with your banner
and making channels easier--
channels and play next
easier for your app.
And lastly with the Play
Store, making sure you opt in
will enable your app to be
discovered on Android TVs.
With that, Lilian's is
going to talk about some
of the cool things
they've been doing.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LILIAN KATIC: Thank
you, Benjamin.
So hi, I'm Lilian from Canal+.
I'm one of the founder of
the Android team in Canada.
And today I'm going
to show you what
we have achieved with
our application myCanal
on the Android TV platform.
So Canal+ is a paid
TV leader in France.
But we are also present on
many parts of the world.
So especially in Europe,
like in Switzerland, Poland,
but also in many
places in Africa,
and also in Asia, like in
Myanmar and in Vietnam.
myCanal is a Canal+
over-the-top platform,
and it's all video hub services.
We provide live TV channels with
our feature called StartOver.
It's a way to let our users
seek in the past of what
has been broadcasted on
our live TV channels.
We have also VOD content
from our partner networks.
Also, we have our
own SVOD service.
Sorry.
And a TVOD service to bring
the news content for all users,
and let them buy or rent them.
So our application
is video centric,
and we needed a great
platform to build them.
And Android TV supports all
the standards of the industry,
starting from the support
of H.264 media codecs
and formats--
H.265s.
And we were thrilled to know
that in the new Q release,
the open source AV1
codecs is made available,
and we can build upon it now.
Also, HDR10+ is on the way.
So video contents
will be even better
on the platform
for less bandwidth.
We are also pleased
today to announce
that we provide
for the first time
4K contents inside myCanal
in exclusivity for Sony TV
sets for now.
So it's really a great time
to build a video application
on the Android TV platform.
So as I said, we are a
video centric application,
and we needed to build
upon a great player.
And we chose to use ExoPlayer,
and I will tell you why.
So it's the heart of the
experience of our services,
and we needed to handle
many technologies
inside the application.
And as you can
see on this slide,
ExoPlayer handles many, many
features and capabilities,
from the management of DRM,
timelines, media composition,
the support of the standards
of the adaptive streamings.
There is a lot of
containers available.
captioning technologies.
And also, ExoPlayer
gives you nice extensions
to make your work easier--
for example, MediaSession to
plug Assistant to the player--
and some other one.
So here are some
highlights of what
we have used inside myCanal.
So it makes sense
to use ExoPlayer
inside the application.
So I will describe four use
cases of the use of ExoPlayer.
So to start off, media
sources is the entry point
of your video playback.
And it will handle all the
transport streams you need.
In myCanal, we used dash
media sources, [INAUDIBLE]
sources and HLS media sources.
So each media sources have
a factory with ExoPlayer,
and it's really easy
to instantiate them.
And everything is rooted
with the URI of the manifest
you want to play.
The factories of the media
sources from ExoPlayer
is very be powerful because
you can customize it.
For example, you may want to
have a custom manifest parser
to handle the feature
that is not handled
by default by ExoPlayer.
You can also adjust your
position of your live streams
on the live TV channels.
And you have also a load error
policy that you can customize.
And here it's a great
feature to handle the load
errors that you may encounter
during your playback.
For example, your
manifest can describe
video chunks that
are not completely
available on your server.
And you may get, for
example, some 412 HTTP error.
And you don't want to make your
playback showing some errors,
so you have to keep in
mind you may need to retry
the loading of your chunks.
So customizing your load error
policy solves this problem.
OK, one other powerful
feature of ExoPlayer
is media composition and the
interactive media ad extension
from ExoPlayer use it
and it's really useful
to concatenate your content
with the ads and video
content in a single timeline.
How you use the IMA extension.
Of course you need the player.
And also you have to
[INAUDIBLE] IMA Ads
Loader, where you will put the
vast ads URI needed to retrieve
all the ad's content.
And also all the ad's
impression you have to handle
gave to the IMA ads and
all the other player
because during the playback,
the IMA ads extension
will handle all the
ad's impression for you.
Then the build media source,
the content you want to play.
And next, just instantiate
your ad media source
and give it to it your
content media source.
And also you need
to give it to it
player view because the
IMA ad extension will
provide for you the
interactive URI for your ads.
Prepare your player and
you're ready to have
a nice playback of
[INAUDIBLE] inside your video.
And everything is
handled nicely.
You will not have
any buffering time
between the transition
of each videos thanks
to some magic of
ExoPlayer caching.
OK, let's talk about DRM.
Android TV platform supports
the two main DRM agents
that the content
owners industry trusts.
It's Google Widevine
and Microsoft PlayReady.
And thanks to these
two DRM agent,
we are able to
provide 4K contents.
ExoPlayer gives you great
tools to manage DRMs.
So you have a
media DRM interface
which is exposed by ExoPlayer.
And you have a callback to
execute the key request, which
would be triggered by
the DRM session which
is in the work during
the video decoding.
And when it's triggered,
you just have to route which
of the two DRM [INAUDIBLE]
for example, if you
get a Widevine unique idea.
You may want to request your
Widevine license server.
And the same thing
for the PlayReady one.
You may want to
root your license
request to the good server.
Depending on the
scenario, you may
want to use one or
another DRM arrangement.
It's up to you.
So how do we start the
playback with their DRM?
So as you saw, we
need our DRM callback.
Then we have to inject it
to a DRM session manager.
The DRM session manager will
handle all the DRM session
that's the playback we need and
will handle all the requests
of license you need.
Instantiate your
player and inject it
in the context of ExoPlayer.
And that's it.
Your playback is ready.
If you want to find out
more about ExoPlayer,
just follow this link.
And I'd recommend you to watch
IU17 session of the ExoPlayer
player, where all the
architecture is really
well described.
OK, in myCanal, we
have also embraced
all the features the Android
TV platform offers to us.
And first, we embrace
the home screen.
We've added a lot of TV
channels inside myCanal.
And it's really, really powerful
because it give us the freedom
to let our user customize
their experience as they want.
And it gives the
ability to our user
to find their content just by
one click on the home screen.
We use also the nice and smooth
transition of the [INAUDIBLE]
show and video previews.
So as you see, even if your
picture contents are not
to the same ratio as the
video, the launcher of Android
handles it with a nice
and smooth animation.
Of course, myCanal
is Assistant ready,
and we use it to essentially
handle the playback controls
of the player of myCanal.
We use it to launch
any playback we want.
For example, if we want to watch
the newest movies on myCanal,
we just have to ask
Assistant, and we play it
automatically for you.
But one of the
powerful feature is
the combination of
the power of Assistant
and our live TV streams.
As I said earlier, we have
the StartOver feature.
And for any live TV
channels on myCanal,
we can seek into the
past up to eight hours.
That means we can ask
the Assistant to start
from the beginning of
any content we want.
And if you have your great TV
shows, which is already on air
you can ask Assistant to
start from the beginning.
Or you may want also
to ask Assistant
to bring back to
the first episode,
in this case, if you want.
That's not it.
We wanted to push the Android
TV platform to it's limits.
And I will show you two great
feature we did inside myCanal.
The first one is what
we call the expert mode.
It's a service for
all live events--
especially for sports-- where
we bring real-time statistic
for all users.
So it's available for
soccer, rugby, golf, and also
for Formula 1 and
Moto Grand Prix.
We've also added
for Moto Grand Prix
a new feature which
we provide, a 360 dash
cam behind any backs of racers.
And you can, inside your
myCanal phone or TV,
watch the progress of
race driver at any angle.
It is very immersive and
very, very interesting.
OK, so next one is Multi-Live.
Multi-Live is pushing the limits
of the Android TV platform.
So in this example, you have
four instances of ExoPlayer,
and we have to tweak
a lot of things
to make the playback
very seamlessly.
These animation are powered
by the control set animation.
We also have to synchronize
all the other [INAUDIBLE]
of all the [INAUDIBLE]
player at the same time.
And we have to know where the
adaption of the player which
are not in front of the users.
And higher up, the
one which is at the--
which is [INAUDIBLE].
Sorry.
So the caveat is that not any
devices can handle Multi-Live,
and we had to determine
which one is capable or not.
So ExoPlayer gives you a little
tool on the media [INAUDIBLE]
to give you how many
instances a device can handle.
But do not trust it at 100%
because, first, a device
can lie to you.
And also you may have another
application using any codecs
behind your application.
So it's a bit
confusing, but it's also
a nice way to the determine
how many instances a device can
handle.
So that's it.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
BENJAMIN BAXTER:
Hey, thanks, Lilian.
Well, thank you all
for coming today.
We've covered a lot of stuff.
Shalini started talking
about the momentum
and how we keep growing year
over year as Android TV.
Anwar came in and talked
about where we're investing,
making your content
more discoverable,
how were doubling down on Google
Play billing in the Play Store.
I talked about some
best practices.
And Lilian talked about how
we apply them in his own app.
So I'm sure you have
tons of questions.
Please come next
door to the Sandbox.
We'll happily answer them.
If you have an app and you
want it to be reviewed,
and you've talked to engineers
on the UX team from Android TV,
come over to App Reviews.
We're right across the way.
And sign up and
it's easy coming in.
So thank you very
much for coming today.
This would not be
possible without you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]